space landings are always tense
touchdown
an explosion cushions the sawyer's
capsule's impact after falling from 250
miles up
but if you were looking for evidence of
the collapse of u.s russian relations
over ukraine you weren't going to find
it in this scene
u.s astronaut mark van der hai all
smiles after nearly a year in space with
russian colleagues even a welcome
message from russian mission control
near moscow
after the invasion eyes turned upward to
the international space station to see
how the u.s russian and german crew were
coping with the crisis
publicly at least it was beneath them
people
have problems on earth on orbit uh we
are like
we are not like we are one crew
and i think uh isis is like symbol of
the friendship and corporations
and
like symbol of future of
exploration of space
the arrival of a russian replacement
crew in what appeared to be ukrainian
colours caused a flurry of speculation
but quickly was dismissed by roscosmos
the russian space agency as total
coincidence but back on earth things are
falling apart
the two sides were going separate ways
for a number of years
long before ukraine i would say it
started probably with georgia in 2008
and accelerated with crimea in 2014 and
now it's a you know fast-moving train
essentially the damage is already done
and damage is extremely extensive beyond
human space flight right
beyond the international space station
the iss must endure for now without
modification it can't stay in orbit
without both u.s and russian modules but
the ultimate fate of the 22-year 150
billion collaboration was probably
sealed when vladimir putin invaded
ukraine undocking confirmed